marvel spider-man miles morales feels
like the second half to the city that
never sleeps
the expansion to 2018's marvel
spider-man and
unfortunately its gameplay never quite
manages to break free of that feeling
that isn't necessarily a bad thing
i like 2018 spider-man for its engaging
combat loot so i'm glad spider-man miles
morales emulates it
it's just that sometimes spider-man
miles morales can feel too similar to
what's come before which can get in the
way of establishing miles as his own
brand of superhero
regardless the familiar trappings of
spider-man miles morales are used to
tell an entirely fresh story with a few
brand new faces
and it's that narrative and those
characters that manage to distinguish
spider-man miles morales as an open
world action game that's compelling to
play
okay
the main plot of the game sees miles try
to garner the favor of new york by
fulfilling requests left by random new
yorkers on a smartphone app as well as
stop the escalating conflict between
roxanne energy corporation and a gang
called the underground the story is your
standard superhero affair with betrayals
and ramifications that are familiar to
the genre
but still exciting to watch unfold if
anything it's the characters who manage
to keep the campaign from feeling
formulaic the tinkerer especially the
game humanizes a classic but somewhat
bland member of spidey's rogues gallery
and gives them a compelling reason for
why they turn to a life of crime
reinventing the character into more of a
tragic figure in a certain light the
tinkerer's actions could be construed to
be almost
heroic in an anti-hero sort of way
allowing the character to exist as a
dark foil to mile spider-man
and at the center of that comparison
between miles and tinkerer is their
shared life experiences the man you
answer to
simon krieger is a killer
this plaza is a monument to everything
he's done
i won't let it open prior to miles
regular interactions with the tinkerer
his evolution as a hero is primarily
seen through his closest friends and
confidants
miles is surrounded by heroes so a small
but significant part of spider-man miles
morales is his musings about who he
should be taking inspiration from
his friends serve as two sides of a coin
playing the roles of angels and devils
in the debates that will define
miles genki for example knows that miles
is spider-man
and understands what miles wants to get
out of the role but can't really
empathize with miles black or puerto
rican heritage
other friends and allies however more
closely relate to miles cultural
identities and struggles but don't
understand the extent of his secret
identity
miles regularly talks to key members of
the supporting cast throughout the first
half of the campaign
you get to see him coming to an
understanding of what type of hero he
wants to be
through these conversations it's awesome
and so when he dons his traditional
black and red suit and emerges as a
brand new spider-man for the first time
one similar to but also altogether
different from peter parker spider-man
you can understand how he's grown to
this point you got to see it you got to
live through that internal turmoil
with him the child of a black father and
puerto rican mother
miles is a wonderful mixture of cultures
and languages the way he leaps off of
rooftops and flips backwards to face the
camera before falling into a head first
dive is just
full of the exaggerated swagger of a
black teen it gives me goosebumps every
time he does it
especially as the music begins to swell
speaking of we've got to talk about the
music
when miles begins swinging the
orchestral score grows louder but
there's a nice synthetic hip-hop
undercurrent to the whole thing
the music crackles with a soft
percussion it reverberates in your ears
with a steady crescendo that
stops just short of overtaking the
sounds of the city
it allows you to remain clued into new
york even while miles is soaring through
the air at breakneck speeds
[Music]
hey uncle aaron what's up hey how's your
jump shot these days
unfortunately spider-man miles morales
can't slow down enough for you to really
immerse yourself in the music that plays
in the open world if genki isn't calling
to direct miles to his next objective
then it's mile's mother
checking in or his uncle offering some
advice or j jonah jameson ranting about
the new web swinging menace or
someone else the game is constantly
cutting off the music to deliver a new
waypoint for you to follow or a
conversation to listen to before the new
waypoint appears
you can turn some of these voices off
but many are tied to the story so you'll
have someone almost always yapping in
your ear
this is largely because of spiderman
miles morales is pacing miles acquires a
series of gadgets and abilities at a
fairly steady pace
swinging from one high key set piece to
the next this works for its frantic
introduction as the sheer whiplash of
needing to constantly adapt to different
types of gameplay in such a short time
puts you right into miles headspace
however because that pacing never really
lets up it can feel like spider-man
miles morales is almost
rushing towards its conclusion desperate
to deliver on the promise that miles
ends the game as a seasoned spider-man
without
really slowing down to show you how he
manages to earn the respect and
appreciation of his city
speaking of spider-man miles morales new
york is largely the same as the one in
2018 spider-man the game does look
better on ps5 but it isn't a drastic
difference
after extensive testing on ps5 the
consensus among gamespot staff is that
the technical features provided by ps5's
dualsense controller don't add anything
meaningful to the gameplay either so
you're getting a similar experience
whether you're playing on ps4
or ps5 regardless of where you're
playing the city is a lot more stunning
while
in motion taking a break from web
swinging or fighting crime to walk on
the streets and high-five pedestrians
reveals somewhat
drab npc designs in no meaningful way
for miles to interact with his fellow
citizens
given that one of mile's biggest
motivations in the game is to connect
with the people of his city it's
disappointing that there's no way to do
so
outside of the new app request side
missions between chapters
miles typically muses aloud that he
should take a moment to respond to
requests for help on his app and it's in
these bite-sized stories that you get to
see miles interacting with his community
albeit with shallow forgettable
characters say for a man who needs you
to rescue his cat and a girl who's deaf
and
might have a crush on miles and honestly
i think it says a lot that i can only
remember the cat's name and that's only
because it's spider-man which is very
memorable
spider-man
did you have an adventure but you have
to purposely keep selecting these
missions otherwise you get a call after
you complete one
to let you know where to go next for the
main campaign so you can either disrupt
the overall flow of the main campaign to
do side activities
or keep up with the pace of the main
story which largely means rushing
forward from chapter to chapter
it's a rather annoying pacing issue
gameplay-wise spider-man mouse morales
is built on the already solid foundation
of 2018 spider-man
relying on a straightforward but still
compelling timing system for both
traversal
and combat web swinging through the air
and catapulting off of rooftops is
effortless to pick up
and combat in stealth sections aren't
that much harder
however despite how approachable the
game is spiderman miles morales still
pushes you to get better by rewarding
you for pulling off more advanced timing
on the tempo of miles web swinging
and combat abilities do you need to use
these harder to time abilities to beat
the game
no but getting the timing down produces
a flow-like rhythm to both traversal and
combat allowing them to more seamlessly
mold together
in an ever more satisfying way over time
though miles controls pretty much
exactly like peter did in 2018
spider-man he has a few unique super
powers venom strikes and camouflage
miles venom strikes offer him area of
effect attacks stunning and damaging
groups of enemies
meanwhile his camouflage allows him to
fairly easily reset a stealth encounter
or perform silent takedowns that peter
couldn't do in the first game
but even without these abilities miles
is as powerful as his mentor
i'd sometimes go entire fights without
using any of the venom attacks because
i forgot that they were there the same
goes for invisibility in some of the
stealth sections
mile's unique powers are his own but
they simply fit into peter's already
established moveset so despite being a
new spider-man miles doesn't actually
play like a new spider-man which feels
like a missed opportunity to use the
gameplay to reinforce that miles brings
his own creative spin
to his mentor's abilities there are
moments where using miles unique powers
would be beneficial but
they're rare relegating the venom
strikes and camouflage to very specific
situations
and since miles is more than competent
without venom or camouflage
the introduction of new enemy types that
can temporarily disable his venom
attacks or see him when he's invisible
don't actually force you to get creative
and tackle challenges in new ways
and so the difficulty of spider-man
miles morales remains fairly flat
throughout the campaign
only spiking for boss battles like i
said at the top of this review
spider-man miles morales feels a lot
like a missing chapter to 2018
spider-man the gameplay is so
similar and the environment is largely
the same it's in the characters
especially genki and the tinkerer and
the story that it tells that the game
manages to break free of what's been
done already to deliver something that
you'll want to see all the way through
spiderman miles morales wastes little
time jumping you to mile's story
and rarely lets up on the brakes packing
the young wall crawler's first solo
outing with more superpowers and radio
chatter than the game needs
and yet despite its frantic pace
spider-man mouse morales is compelling
from a narrative standpoint with a
nuanced villain that helps highlight
why miles is so special his culture it's
mao's unique differences
and earnest attempts at figuring out how
to protect his community and make him
into such a wonderful hero
not the mask he wears and the super
powers he wields
[Music]
you